[Music]
[Music]
i'm the author of manning's new book
refactoring to rust
which is currently in early access
and today we are going to be creating a
very simple tcp chat server
using the rust programming language its
async await features and the tokyo
concurrent programming
library
so we have a
we should be on the stream for about an
hour today
and i plan to be programming for most of
that there are a couple places where
they'll have
sort of natural breaks for questions but
please feel free to ask any questions
that you have just in the stream chat
whenever they come up and
i will address those as soon as i see
them i do have a second screen
down here
that has
that has the stream chat up so i will
try to look at that as frequently as
possible and address those questions as
soon as they come in
so before we get started let's talk
about uh what we're doing today so
rust
as i'm sure you're aware is a
programming language created at mozilla
several years ago in order to
allow developers to create really fast
programs that operate close to the metal
while
sort of saving developers from a lot of
the very common
memory safety pitfalls that languages
like c and c plus have so rust is very
high performance
very low overhead but it also has
compile time guarantees that
save us from doing things like use after
free errors dangling pointers all this
kind of stuff
and the other piece here is tokyo which
is a rust library
that allows us to do
asynchronous io and
other asynchronous operations in
in rust code
so when we say async uh
it's generally
generally only talked about in contrast
with synchronous codes if synchronous
and asynchronous two sides of the way
that you can do operations so
basically when you have a synchronous
operation
[Music]
that might be something like reading
from a file
sleeping in a timer
reading of a network stream
and
so when when you have an operation like
this you know that is going to basically
block your entire threads uh computation
it's going to just sit there it's going
to do nothing
and you know the os will
probably schedule some other threads to
run on your cpu while that thread is
waiting for something to happen
we contrast this with asynchronous
computing where we actually
you know do this these kind of context
switching operations inside of our
applications code
we we maintain state in our application
code that allows
uh part of our application be that a run
time or some kind of scheduler event
loop to swap out different operations
uh and suspend them
when there's nothing to do and then
resume them
once there is some you know resource or
timer or whatever that's that's ready
and good to go
uh so tokyo as i mentioned is a library
which allows us to do these kind of
asynchronous operations in rust and it
has a ton of different features in it it
has timers file io sub processes
uh network network modules everything
everything that canon might uh block in
a normal program tokyo has a facility
for doing in a way that is
uh asynchronous and non-blocking
tokyo is used very very widely across
the rust ecosystem
it's used at some huge companies google
aws
microsoft azure
i use it in my day job at
onesignal we are hiring if you're
interested in a job working with rust
send me an email nate onesignal.com
and yeah tokyo is a fantastic library it
makes it super easy to write really high
performance uh
networked applications with rust and
async computing so today we're going to
be making a very simple chat server and
basically this is just going to allow
multiple tcp tcp clients to connect up
to the chat server
when one client sends a message up to
the server the message will be broadcast
to all of the different clients that are
connected
[Music]
so we can have a really really simple uh
chat session that's uh that's going on
yeah so
are there any questions from anybody on
the stream about anything that i've said
so far
don't see anything so we're going to
just jump right ahead once again
if you have any questions at any point
during the stream please please
just dump those in the stream chat as
soon as possible
and i will answer those immediately as i
see them
very
willing to be interrupted so do not do
not shy away from that also
i want to point out there's a
discount code at the top of the screen
for my book refactoring to rust
refactoring to rust is all about how you
can take code that's written in non-rust
programming languages and actually
swap out the performance critical or
memory safety critical piece of your
code
and rewrite just that tiny little piece
and rust while keeping your larger
system intact so it's not always
feasible to
rewrite an entire application
in a new programming language that's a
very
often touted thing as as good to do
however it's very often that you
underestimate the complexity of that and
what may be much more impactful
uh is actually taking that very small
piece that has a big performance impact
and just swapping out that piece
and that is what we talk about in my
book refactoring to russ so if you'd
like to check that out and get 40 off
that there's a discount code at the top
of the screen there twit mara40
so check that out on manning's website
manning.com
so
without further ado we can go ahead and
jump
into
the coding
so if you've written absolutely any rust
before you should recognize
this this is the
standard hello world program that you
get when you start a new rust project
with cargo so this is you know totally
blank project there's nothing in here at
all
except
the hello world
so before
before we start writing any rust code
we are going to need to add in
one additional library which is of
course the tokyo library
so i'll just drop that in my cargo
tunnel file
and
you may not be familiar with this exact
syntax if you've
not been using rust for a super long
time
but
rust has conditional compilation flags
that you can use to trigger different
features
in
libraries and basically what this allows
you to do is tokyo basically is a very
large library it has lots of features
lots of
things that you might not need in every
single program so for example if you're
making a web server you probably don't
need to have tokyo's you know sub
process module turned on
so these conditional compilation
features allow you to control which
things are included and which things are
not included for our purposes we're
enabling everything uh because i don't
feel like uh enumerating them for this
stream
but this is you know
this is just uh including version one of
tokyo with every single feature enabled
great
now that we have tokyo included as a
library we can start writing some rust
code for our async chat server
so
before we can start writing any
functional code actually we need to make
some slight edits to our main function
so right now it's a normal main function
that works with any old rust program we
actually need to turn this
into an async main function and
immediately after doing that we are
confronted with what will probably be
the first of many compiler errors that
we'll run into the compiler trying to
help us out and stop us from
generating an invalid program
main has an invalid return type impul
future
so
by default
the rust programming language has no
idea how
multiple asynchronous computations
should be interleaved with each other
basically how they should be executed
so in order to actually run any async
computations
which russ calls futures
we need to
provide rust with the
with an executor a thing that knows how
to run a future and drive it to
completion
so a future is basically a
value
that does not have
uh
it's basically a thing that does not
have a known value yet but it may have a
known value at some point
uh later on down the line so this might
be
you know a network read request right so
let's say an http request you send a
http request to you know get google.com
um
you are you're not gonna know what comes
back from that for you know maybe 100
milliseconds
so as soon as you send that request
immediately you'll get a future back
and that future will just be in a
pending state where it's waiting for the
network transaction to complete and then
eventually that that network transaction
will complete and your future will be in
a completed or a resolved state
so basically you know we need to create
a main function and rust is basically
just going to take it our async function
and wrap that up into something that
returns a future with a lot of
compile-time magic that actually
generates a very efficient
state machine for us
however as i mentioned russ does not
know how to run a future
by itself it knows how to generate
futures it's great generating features
but it does not know how to execute a
future
so the way we can fix this
uh is there's a procedural macro that's
available from tokyo
call tokyo main
and i can wrap the main function in
tokyo main and basically what this does
is it takes
our async function async main function
which is typically invalid and turns it
into a
normal main function with some tokyo
stuff inside of it
but this just saves us a little bit of
boilerplate code writing
so if we try running this program now
it works exactly the same as a normal uh
hello world program and russ does you
know there's there's nothing uh
special or magical or weird that's going
on just yet um so we get our hello world
on the console just like we expect
so that's great
so
we're not going to go straight from
hello world to having a chat server
there's going to be some incremental
steps that we're going to need to take
and the first incremental step that
we're going to take is
to make a tcp
echo server so basically
this is a server that will sit there it
will wait for a client to connect
and once
once a client has connected
it will take any message the client
sends and bounce it right back to the
client so just like the echo program you
know echoes any message that you send to
it the tcp echo server is going to echo
any uh any message that it receives
right back to the client
let's go ahead and
create that
the first thing that we're going to need
is a tcp listener
now this is a type that's coming from
tokyo
and
it's uh you know it's basically just
going to sit there
listening for
incoming connect requests on the port
and uh
oops sorry
and it's going to you know allow those
clients to connect
so
if i
if i look at the return type here of tcp
listener bind we can see that it's a
impul future
and the output type is result tcp
listener error
so because this return type is an impul
future if i want to get to this result
that's inside of the future i need to
use dot
a weight
to get that result out so we can now see
that uh we are getting uh that result
out there and a weight is a rust keyword
that tells
the rust compiler hey
when you get to this point
you're allowed to suspend this function
until
this future that's on the left side of a
weight
resolves and is ready and has an item
that's available to do some processing
on
so a weight
very similar to
node.js or c sharp or you know any other
language that has a weight
in rust it just means suspend this
current task until our future is ready
to be acted on
so now that we have a weight there and
you know this is giving us back a result
i will add
unwrap for some very
basic and not great error handling
so we have a tcp listener
and we are ready to start accepting
connections so if you've done any kind
of socket programming before
you will probably know what is coming
next
which is
to call the accept method on our tcp
listener
accept is a method
very similar to how it sounds that uh
oops sorry this is not socket it's
listener uh accept is a method that
accepts a new connection from a tcp
listener and yields uh
the connection as well as the address of
the connection
so uh similar to bind
except returns a future
and that future
outputs a result so i will have my await
unwrap on there so we can see now that
we have a socket which is a tcp stream
and we have an adder which is a socket
adder
we're not going to use the address for
now so i'm going to
underscore that so i don't get
unused warnings
and we have our socket
now
if i were to if i were to run this
program
right now and try connecting to it with
a telnet client
telnet localhost
8080.
we can see the connection is accepted
and then immediately closed and our rust
program
it exits because of course
we set up a tcp listener we accept a
single connection and then we exit
there's nothing else that happens
afterwards
so what we're going to need to do now is
we're going to need to read something in
from the client and then we're going to
need to write that same thing back out
to the same client
so if we want to read
some new data into memory from a network
stream we need a little buffer to put
the data into
so i will create a buffer
in the form of a stack array
it's just one one kilobyte
1024
u8s or 1024 bytes
and create that and then i can call
socket.read
and this again is an async function
so it's going to suspend execution until
the read has finished and it's going to
return a result
and this error that we're receiving now
is because read is actually associated
with a trait in tokyo the async read ext
trait
and that's because
um
that's because all the items in tokyo
that that implement their async read
trait
they just want to implement a single
item
for uh for example the socket it just
implements
a method called i think it's uh
poll read
and then this wrapper trait async read
ext actually has all the
the things that end users of the library
might want to use to do higher level
read operations
uh so this error cannot borrow socket as
mutable it's very easy to solve of
course we just declare our socket
variable as mutable and uh and now this
is going to compile
and then socket.read actually returns
the number of bytes that were read
from the stream onto the buffer so the
buffer has a
1024
bytes on it
has space for 1024 bytes to be read into
memory however
uh we might actually read a lot fewer
than that in when we call socket.read
so we need to use this bytes red
to
truncate our buffer when we send it back
to the client
so to send back i'm going to use socket
dot write all
and a common confusion point with write
all is it does not write a message to
every socket that is connected to a tcp
listener
instead it writes every single byte that
is in the input buffer uh out onto the
output buffer so
it's very common especially when you're
not writing naturally async code like
you have with tokyo
to use uh
just write instead of write all and then
to actually intercept
calls to write that would naturally
block
and then to do your own kind of
scheduling uh with with write calls to
make sure that you never block any of
your uh i o threads since we have tokyo
doing that for us it's not necessary we
can use write all and we can not worry
about having to manually advance our own
cursors or things like that
so i'll pass in
buffer
and up to the number of bytes red
and then similar to the read ext trait
there's an async right ext trait that i
need to import in order to get right all
to work
so now if i run uh
the server
and i connect a client
i write hello we can see now it is
actually staying alive and i can write
hello here if i hit enter
this is the hello that i typed and then
there's a hello that comes back
from the server so all seems to be
working exactly as expected
very nice
uh however
maybe we want our echo server to support
more than one message at a time like
right now it just operates on on one
message and then it exits and we have to
restart the server so
not only can we not have more than one
client we can't even have more than one
message extremely limiting right so
a great first incremental step is going
to be to make this support multiple
messages sent at a time so
we can do that by
adding an infinite loop
so as soon as one client connects we'll
drop into this infinite loop and we'll
start reading messages and writing them
out
i can go ahead and recompile rerun that
hello
how are you excellent
so we have our very basic tcp echo
server is reading messages writing
messages
more than one message
at a time it can handle
so i'll go ahead and exit that now
and
there's another uh change that i would
like to do here so right now we have
this buffer that we're managing
ourselves or you know
truncating it before we pass it to right
and all this stuff it's a little uh not
great to use so i'd like to introduce
some extra
helpers that that could be a little bit
more
uh
what we call idiomatic uh rust
so tokyo has a very helpful type in it
for doing i o operations
called buff read
sorry buff reader
and a buff reader
excuse me
a buff reader it works the same as the
buff reader type in the standard library
if you're familiar with that
essentially what that is is it wraps any
kind of reader it maintains its own
buffer
and it allows you to do some higher
level read operations like for example
read an entire line of text from a
stream
uh so we have our
buff reader
and we actually also need a string to
store each line
and instead of calling socket.read
i'm going to call
reader
dot read line
and i'll pass it a reference mutable
reference to our line buffer
and once again this has a uh extension
trait that's that it's associated with
that we need to import in order to make
this work correctly
and then
instead of
instead of passing buffer here we're
actually going to pass
line dot as
bytes
because that will
give us the underlying bytes
from our string
once again if there are any questions
about anything that i'm doing please
feel free to ask those immediately you
know the twitch stream and i will
address those just as soon as they come
up
so this is failing now because we're
trying to move our socket into this buff
reader and of course you cannot move
something in a loop because there's only
one thing to be moved
so i'm going to go ahead and move the
reader and the string creation
outside of that loop so that they
they work a little bit better
now we're getting a pro we're getting an
error because we are borrowing a moved
value socket so the buff reader has
taken ownership of the socket
and there's now nothing
we're now not allowed to use the socket
outside of the buff reader
because it has it has that ownership of
it
so how can we resolve this the way that
we can do this is using the split method
on a socket so many i o handles
you know they have a read part and they
have a right part and tokyo has a split
method which allows us to separate the
read part and the right part so we can
handle them independently as we need to
in this case
read
right
socket dot
split so instead of passing uh
socket to the buff reader i will pass
the read half to the buff reader and
instead of calling socket.writeall i
will call
right let's call it writer
and this can be reader
and we can't borrow writer as mutable
because it is not declared as mutable
it is now great um
reading out messages from the clients
reading out lines i'm sorry from the
client writing them right on back to the
client using a buff reader is what we've
got here and then we do still want to
use this bytes red thing that comes back
from redline because
it's actually going to tell us if a
client has disconnected or not so
if the number of bytes that we read from
the stream is 0
and that actually means that the reader
has reached the end of the file and
there's no data left and
we just want to go ahead and exit
i'll go ahead and take out this unused
import that's up here
and now we should be able to
run our server and connect a client and
it still should work exactly as we
expect
hello
but i'm on this server
ah but we're getting a weird
interleaving of messages here so i typed
i'm glad i'm on this server but i got
back hello i'm glad i'm on this server
if i send a question mark
i get hello i'm glad on this glad i'm on
this server question mark
so let's send one more one more message
goodbye and we get all four messages now
i'll go ahead and disconnect the client
and we can see that the
the rust server exited once as soon as
the client disconnected
uh
but why did we get those repeated
messages it turns out that
when you call read line it actually just
appends
the next line that it reads onto the
string buffer
that you've passed into it so this is
similar to how standard library
functions work it's not really
reedline's job to clear out the input
buffer because
you know you might be reading in a file
one line at a time
so if you want to have a clean string
each time it is your job to do that so
you can very easily add that in here
line dot
clear
let's try that now
hello
so we can see now we are just getting
back the single message
that we send up to the server
so i will go ahead and
disconnect the client
and we can see the server once again has
ended so
we're handling one client great
however
in order to actually
do
any kind of
async computation or really
make use of tokyo at all because really
what we're doing right now could just as
easily
be done with the standard library if not
more easily since we wouldn't have a
weight we wouldn't have tokyo main we
wouldn't have an extra dependency
we don't start to really see the
benefits until we start to get into how
we're handling
multiple clients independently
so if we want to handle multiple clients
independently you know the standard way
that you do that and the way that also
we do it with tokyo is to put
accept
uh in our client handling into a loop
so you know just like down here an
infinite loop for handling one client we
have an infinite loop that every time is
just calling accept to allow a new
client to have access to our server
let's go ahead and try this out
connect connect
connect
hello this works
hello oh no this one does not work
why does this one not work but this one
does
well what happens if i if i disconnect
this one
if i disconnect client 1 client 2 starts
starts to work
client 2 is now able to process messages
so it turns out even though we're using
this beautiful you know async
computation library and we're using a
weight we're actually not doing anything
uh asynchronously at all where
everything we're doing here is is
blocking and i know i said that async
operations do not block
but the thing that async operations
avoid blocking on is the thread level
however
async operations are still perfectly
capable of blocking at the task level
so task is
essentially a unit of work in the in the
async world and it's
it can basically be thought of as a very
lightweight thread
so
these are not os threads they're not os
tasks
they are
things units of asynchronous computation
that tokyo knows about and is able to
very efficiently interleave with each
other and schedule
in
you know optimal ways so it's a it knows
how to sleep one task until its io
resource is ready and then as soon as
the i o resource is ready wake the task
up allow it to continue processing
so right now we basically just have one
single task and that just runs through
in a linear fashion exactly like any
kind of
synchronous program would
so what we actually need to do in order
to
get some kind of concurrency going on
here and to get multiple clients
handling and working correctly is we
need to use a method called
tokyo spawn
to create a new task
so we're going to wrap all of our
handling for an individual client and
this call to tokyo spawn
and that is actually going to
move all of one client's handling onto
its own independent task and we've also
added this this new thing async move
here
so
a lot of languages that have async and a
weight in them have async functions
but
that's that's basically their only unit
of creating
uh an async computation
rust actually has the concept of an
async block
which is
you know basically wrapping up one
little piece of code into its own
uh future its own unit of async work
so we don't need to write this as a
separate function we we could completely
write this as a separate function for
handling one socket
but it's not necessary we can use this
async block
and pass that to tokyo spawn
yes uh so if we compile oops that's not
my compiler commands
if we compile this
and
we start up a few clients
this is the second client that connected
hello it seems to be working
looks like it's working for this first
client too
i can send all kind of messages from
both clients and they both seem to be
handled
a okay no problem
so
to summarize
recall we went from
allowing one client to connect and get
echoed one message back to it to
allowing one client to connect get
arbitrary number of messages sent back
to it to
having a buffered reader
that's using you know
good rust conventions
to allowing multiple clients to connect
by virtue of using a
a separate spawned task that's running
concurrently
with the task that's that's calling
except in a loop
any questions about anything that we had
done
uh there once again please feel free to
drop them in the twitch chat and i will
answer those just as soon as they come
up
so uh
this is a great echo server it supports
multiple clients it sends messages back
to the client that connected however it
is very much not a chat server so
communication is completely siloed
if you have
a hundred thousand clients connected
each client will only ever receive back
messages that they themselves sent so
this is this is uh it's not very good
for fostering a community you know it's
it's uh
it's not a chat server so how do we get
from where we what we have right now to
having a chat server
well basically what we need to do is we
need to communicate this line that's
read from one client
out to every single client who is
connected right now
so the way we're going to do that is by
using a type also from tokyo called a
broadcast channel
[Music]
and a broadcast channel
as the name implies is a special type of
channel
which allows multiple uh producers and
multiple consumers to all send and
receive
uh on a single channel so what that
means in practice
is we can have a
sender and a receiver on every single
task
for uh
for handling our clients
and you know each each client task will
send lines that it reads from its own
client when they're ready and then
it will also receive lines read in from
other clients as soon as they have
written their lines
so broadcast channel
oops
accepts a single argument which is the
number of
uh
the number of items that it can
sort of keep in its internal cues for
the receiver
so i need to import this tokyo sync
broadcast
and we're getting a compiler error now
because it says type inside async block
must be known
in this context so this is a problem
because
if you're familiar with how generics
work in rust you know we can see this is
a channel
with a type parameter on it so it can
support any
type of thing
that is cloneable
and sendable and sync
so
the compiler doesn't know basically what
we're going to send on it so i'm going
to make this compiler error go away
with just a little turbo fish telling it
hey we're going to send strings
on this channel
and now
uh the way that we are going to use our
channel
is uh
after we have read the line from the
client
i will add in a call to tx
dot send
line.clone on here
and now we are getting one of the
famous uh rust compiler errors use of
moved value so this is happening
uh very similar to
when we had buff reader new inside of
our loop before this is happening
because we are trying to move
the value tx into this new task
within a loop so the way we get around
that is by cloning tx
and this returns a result so i'll also
unwrap the result that comes back there
so
we are sending items on the channel
however we are not receiving items on
the channel
so
what we are also going to do in here is
let
message equals
rx dot receive
dot await
dot unwrap
can now borrow rx is mutable as it is
not declared as mutable okay
start with that one
use of moved value rx so similar to how
we're cloning tx we actually need to
have a new value for the receiver on
every single iteration of this loop
and
i'm not sure why the api was designed
like this i'm sure they have a great
reason if you ask the tokyo folks
but the way that you get a new receiver
on a broadcast channel is actually by
pulling it out of the sender so we need
to call tx dot
subscribe and this will give us a new
receiver
and that that does need to be readable
uh so message it's going to come back as
a string and then we're going to change
this out from
line as bytes to
message as bytes
so let's go ahead and start our server
up
and let's connect a couple of clients
hello
okay that looks good
that's interesting
so i sent how are you on client two but
it actually received the message hello
which recall was sent from from client
number one
and if i send another message from
client one i get back that message from
client two
it seems that the the sending order of
our messages is very
mistaken and if we
look at our logic here it's not too hard
to see why
so
we we're saying
read a line from the client
block until you're done reading that
line from the client then as soon as
you've read the line
put something on this queue this uh
this channel
and then immediately after you put
something on the channel
you know sequentially after
read something off the channel and send
that something to the client send
exactly one of those things to the
client
so this is uh
this is a pretty odd structure if you
think about it right
read from the client put something on a
queue
read from the same queue you just put a
thing on and then write that thing to
the client
really this thing
and this thing are both async functions
that could both block an arbitrary
amount of time and really we don't want
them to be dependent on each other at
all really we want to run those two
things
concurrently with each other we want to
run them at the same exact time and
basically just race and see which one
finishes first and act on it you know
when it does finish
so we could accomplish this
by using uh tokyo spawn and having a
separate task
which you know calls rx.receive and then
write stuff out to the
the writers
but
it's it's a little bit
more straightforward if we introduce a
new uh concept
a new tool available to us which is a
macro that tokyo has called select
now if you've done any go programming
before you're probably familiar with a
select statement and it it basically
just allows you to run multiple
asynchronous things concurrently at the
same time and act on the first one that
comes back with a result
so it has
it has its own special little syntax
because it's you know a macro
so the way it works is you give it
and
you give it an identifier
you give it a future
and then you give it
a block of code
and so what it's going to do is it's
going to run the future
it's going to assign the result of the
future to the identifier that you give
it and then it's going to run the block
of code that comes after that
so we're just going to add in
tx
dot send line.clone and
line dot clear right here
and then we still want to maintain our
if bytes read equal zero break
thing here so i'm just going to assign
the return value of read line as
result
and we're just going to say
if
if result.unwrap equals zero then
break yeah
so
similarly to before this is not
this is not going to do anything
concurrently yet because we just have a
single thing inside of select so the way
the way we start to get a benefit here
is once we move multiple things inside
of our select statement
so rx.receive returns a future
and
we can
unwrap that future
message equals
or sorry we won't unwrap the future
select is going to basically
uh
it's going to do a wait on the future
sort of implicitly as a part of the the
the compiler machinery that that it
generates
and we're going to call unwrap on the
result that
comes out of the future
so we've got that oops
this line.clear goes away this
writer.writeal
moves into
our
select
branch right here
so let's go ahead and uh
restart our server
as it is right now
server is running
let's go ahead and connect up
whoops
checked up our clients
we can see that there's the hello
message we typed out there's the one we
received back from the server
and we can see for the first time now
client number two has actually received
a hello message from the server
that was broadcast to it from since
client one sent it
so if i type you know how are you on
client two
you can see that that pops up right over
here in the stream for for client one
there is an additional feature that i
would like to add onto
our server which is you know right now
if you type a message and you send it
you get the same message back that you
sent now obviously if we were actually
writing a chat server we would not be
targeting telnet
as our client software however
in this
demonstration we are using telnet as our
client software and so
we should
try and make a nice experience for all
of our loyal telnet users
so we are not going to echo the same
message that was sent
right back to the client who sent it
so let's let's go ahead and disconnect
our clients stop the server and let's
see if we can't fix the double sending
problem
we have a a really nice easy way that we
can do this which is we can use the
client address that accept gives back to
us let's
take off that underscore there
and we can change our call to send
slightly so instead of just sending the
line of text that we read from the
stream
we can also send the address
of the client that it was read from
so
address comes back from accept
and then address goes into the tokyo
spawn into the async move block
and it gets sent alongside the line that
we read off of the network stream
and then of course we need to pull that
off of the broadcast channel in our
receiver
online 36 we currently just have let
message equals result to unwrap
let's destructure that into message and
other
adder
and then we're going to wrap this right
all in
if
adder is not equal to other adder
and of course these types are mismatched
because we told that hey this is a
string broadcast channel it's only going
to have one string on it
we need to take this turbo fish off
because it's actually going to have a
tuple of string and socket address on it
so we only needed the the turbo fish
there because we had no calls to send we
had no calls to receive so the compiler
wasn't smart enough to oh sorry the
compiler didn't have enough information
yet to figure out what kind of values
were going to be sent on this channel
but now that we now that we're calling
send we're calling receive it has enough
information to
determine the types that are being used
without
the turbo fish
so that
let's uh go ahead and run it and just
verify that it works
all as we are expecting
so i type hello world on client one it
shows up in client two
two can go to one let's see if i if i
add in a third one here
third client can connect and immediately
its messages are being broadcast to one
and two
and it gets messages
that are sent from clients
one and two as well
and if i disconnect
one of my clients this client right here
we don't start to get
um
we do not start to get um errors or
anything like that that shows up in the
stream ah there's a question in the
twitch twitch chat what is a turbo fish
uh turbofish is a an operator that is
pretty unique to rust
it is essentially a way to
hint to the compiler
what kind of generic type you expect to
be returned from a function so
if
let's let's come up with a really simple
example of how a turbo fish might be
helpful
let's say
let's say i want to write a function
that returns the default value for a
type any type
i can write that pretty easily
give me
default
that's going to have a type argument t
that's going to take no parameters and
it's going to return a t
and we're just going to say
default
default
default is a trait that's in the rust
standard library which
some types have a default value like
integers default to zero
boolean defaults to
false
lists and strings default to empty
collections most collections default to
empty collections things like this so
that just makes it easier to
uh
to you know well provide default values
for your types because it's built right
into the standard language standard
library so if i add a little trace out
on here that says where t implements
defaults then it'll actually compile
and then if i try to use this
but value equals give me default we're
going to get a compiler error that says
type inside async block must be known in
this context because the compiler is
like hey
this give me default function could
return almost anything you know there
are so many types to implement default
how could i possibly know
what you expect me to return
so there's a couple ways we could solve
this like in this instance obviously
we could just add a type annotation to
the variable binding but sometimes that
that doesn't work if you're using uh a
function call as a part of a larger
expression so another way that we can
get around this is to use what's known
as the the turbofish operator which just
looks like this it's two colons uh
followed by
the greater than less than braces which
which are used for tight parameters and
rust
so this is called a turbo fish because i
guess it you know it sort of looks like
a fish
i guess you know there's the head
there's the back of its body and there's
the tail there's actually a uh
there's a fan website that somebody made
turbo dot fish
that has a bunch of animations of these
little
turbo fish
operators swimming around a black screen
so that is the turbo fitch you turbo
fish used for
disambiguating generic types that the
compiler is not smart enough to figure
out by itself
i see that i
provided a good explanation so thank you
um
yeah we have a couple more minutes and
there are some additional features that
we could add here we could you know make
this slightly more in-depth uh but
before we do that are there any
additional questions on anything
that we talked about here
not seeing anything on the chat so i
think we can
go right ahead so one additional uh
change that we could make is you know we
could say hey what if this broadcast
channel that tokyo provides
what if that were actually uh not
available to us you know
it can sometimes be helpful to think
about um
think about how we distribute messages
in an asynchronous uh program like this
and uh
one way that we can make that
slightly more clear
is to you know essentially re-implement
the functionality of this
broadcast channel actually now that i
think about it i think that may take a
little bit more time than we have
available to us
in eight minutes and it may take some
more explanation uh so we're actually
not not going to do that but i do have
some additional content that we can talk
about one thing that's pretty frequently
asked
when seeing
this program is how do i know when to
use tokyo spawn
to do things concurrently and how do i
know when to use tokyo select and this
is a a really valid
uh concern that people have because like
you know you told me two different ways
that i can do concurrency how do i know
when one is appropriate versus the other
and a really good rule of thumb is
you know select is
very useful when you have things that
need to operate on the same
shared state and you have a finite
number of things
so for example
in this example
we have exactly two async tasks that
need to run concurrently right we have
reading a line from the network and we
have receiving on this internal
broadcast channel in memory
those are the only two things that are
ever going to need to run concurrently
you know within the scope of this one
task
we're never going to have a third thing
or a fifth thing or whatever
so select it is better in this case
and in addition to just having the two
things we also have some shared state it
might not be obvious but let's take a
closer look
we can see that you know we have we we
did a split on the socket
and if we look at the type that you get
back from split
you have a read half and a right half
and you may notice that the read half
and the right half actually have
lifetime parameters associated with them
that are matched up with a mutable
borrow
of the tcp stream
and if we jump into the the types here
you can actually see that the read half
and the right half are implemented just
as
uh references to the tcp stream the
underlying tcp stream
so
if we actually tried to spawn
these two things as independent tokyo
task we would run into a problem because
we would tr we'd be trying to
split a reference
across multiple tasks which is is not
allowed
because anytime you call tokyo spawn the
thing that you pass into it has to be
static so it has to have no
uh like stack references in it
and it has to be
send and
sync sync does not explicitly appear in
the bounds but trust me it has to be
synced to
so if we tried if we
you know i can do it
uh tokyo
spawn
async
move
uh and we'll just just make this really
simple we're just gonna put this one
this one call in here and that's
actually going to
invalidate everything because it's uh
oh
type annotations
uh we now get the air socket does not
live long enough
which uh you know you may be familiar
with getting errors like this from the
borrow checker and rust if you've you
know done anything more complicated than
like a hello world or a fizzbuzz
this is essentially saying us saying to
us that hey
you are calling this function down here
that needs the reference to socket to be
a static reference but it's not a static
reference
argument requires that socket is
borrowed for static
and it's not so
that that doesn't that doesn't work it's
uh
it's not super explicit but you know
basically because of the way split works
we do have some shared state between the
two branches of these in the form of the
reader and the writer which both point
to the same underlying
piece of memory
so it's very common in
writing programs with tokyo like a
really common pattern
that i will have is
a select statement that has you know
five or six branches on it that are all
just gathering messages from different
channels uh like this
and then altering some shared state like
um
you know say error counters or something
like this that's uh
that's you know
part of an instance variable you know
something like that so if you were using
tasks for that independent task to read
off all those channels
all that kind of shared state would need
to be behind you know atomics or mutexes
things like that so that your
communication
wouldn't risk a data race but select
allows that to happen you know very
naturally in a very sensible way one
thing to point out that that is sort of
a unique piece of select
is the stuff that's in these branches
you know
line 27
can
and i can't have a multi multi-cursor
line 35 and line 27 those two can
operate at the same time as each other
however
as soon as it jumps into one of these
blocks that's going to be the only thing
that's running
so as soon as reader.readline finishes
and there's a line that's available to
to be acted on
it's going to jump down into this block
and it's
it's going to suspend
this future
and this future can't be executing
and same thing here if we receive
something on the broadcast channel
it's going to suspend this future and
there's no way this future can be
running so you get sort of a
free
like locking free
concurrency guarantees
just by virtue of the way that
select works
and another really nice feature of
select that you don't get with spawn is
because it all happens on the same task
you know you can really easily share
references
between uh all the different branches of
select
and you know it just makes memory
management a lot easier you don't have
to worry about making everything owned
making everything static and sync and
all this stuff
yeah
so uh we are just about at the time
limit so i i will take another
opportunity to
uh
to plug my book which is refactoring to
rust refactoring to rust new book by
manning it's all about
making your programs
more efficient without rewriting them
from the ground up just find that one
little piece of performance sensitive
code
swap that
with some rust code
maybe you know add some glue code to
figure out exactly how the two pieces
are going to interact
and
uh you know you'll have a much more
performant program
uh there's a 40 off code in the
link or sorry it's not a link in the the
banner above twit mara40 you can use
that at manning.com to get 40 off
refactoring to rust
it's in early access now the first three
chapters are currently available and the
fourth chapter is hopefully coming very
very
soon
thank you so much to everybody who
watched on the stream today i think it's
going to be saved on manning's twitch
channel and then manning's youtube page
thank you to manning for hosting
also once again if you're looking for a
job please email me nate onesignal.com
we are hiring uh rust developers go
developers
uh
ruby javascript developers anybody and
everybody
uh nate onesignal.com happy to talk to
you about opportunities thank you again
to everybody who watched on the stream
today
um
i am dropping off now
have a lovely evening rest of the day
everybody